the fast family's 10th chapter is over
or is it after that stunner of an ending
it's clear that there's more Story to
Tell in the world of the Fast and the
Furious here's what the movie's credit
scene tells us about all the action to
come morning spoilers ahead for fast X
in case you run out to the theater to
take off on some of your own street
racing action you should know there's a
mid-credits scene after the last shots
of fast X and it has massive
implications for the future of the
franchise Dwayne Johnson being in the
movie has been spoiled for a little
while now but the devils and the details
when Dominic Toretto and his team closed
the movie with the last explosive
Cliffhanger this scene sets the stage
for what's next the big credit scene
shows a giant mass man dugged out in a
high-tech military gear investigating an
abandoned building inside the voice of
Dante Reyes can be heard taunting him
Dante makes threats to the mask's figure
promising nothing short of a meeting
with the devil to pay for his sins
against his father Hanan Reyes then we
get the big reveal well Don may have
been the one who pulled off the heist
that killed Dante's father he wasn't
actually the one to pull the trigger
that would be none other than Dwayne
Johnson's Larger than Life character
special agent Luke Hobbs
how are you oh
how much you call an ice cold can of
whoop ass right on cue the masked man
pulls down his disguise and reveals a
glorious goated face of Luke Hobbs
returning to the Fast and Furious
Universe for the first time since 2019's
Hobbs and Shore while his presence in
the movie is a pretty big throwback on
its own hob says vibe in fast X also
feels much more reminiscent of his
characterization in Fast Five even in
this brief teaser Johnson is clearly
leaning into the cartoonish gritty rage
the Hobbs exuded in his first appearance
on the franchise it's a bit of a
reversal from the Dwayne Johnson charm
the actor brought to the role in later
movies like the fate of the Furious and
Hobbs ensure he even grants out a
perfect some to boot hello you son
a scene is everything fast fans
could have hoped for and this especially
shocking given all the behind the scenes
blusters surrounding Vin Diesel and
Dwayne Johnson's professional
relationship Johnson's return was
revealed online almost a week before the
film's release it likely gave some fans
flashbacks to a similar incident last
year when the post credit team for
Johnson's Black Adam was also spoiled
seemingly on purpose a week before its
release the news that Johnson was
returning to the fast franchise came as
a major surprise following a public Feud
and apparent Fallout with Vin Diesel the
actor had previously stated clearly on
multiple occasions that he had no
interest in returning to the fast Saga
outside of future Hobson Shore Secours
even after a public appeal from diesel
for his co-star to return to fast X it's
possible that Johnson's initial decision
was made when he was planning to devote
the next several years of his career to
building a universe around the DC Comics
character Black Adam flans that seem to
have been scuttled after a change in
leadership at DC Studios perhaps the
decision not to rejoin was more
professional than personal and the
cancellation of future Black Adam
sequels gave Johnson Space to recommit
to the fast franchise in any case Hobbs
has returned to the Fast and Furious
Universe can really only be a great
thing as the character opens up more
organic storytelling opportunities for
the upcoming sequels to explore but have
sacred even finally reveal the true
identity the etn director introduced in
Hobbs and Shore regardless of how it
shakes out in future films it's just
exciting to see Johnson returning to one
of his most iconic roles we're going to
have a hard time waiting for his reunion
with the rest of tarato's crew in the
upcoming sequels to fast X
foreign
[Music]